[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfoco su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de Francia y cuatro que hoy dedicamos Al
Día Internacional de la lucha por los
derechos de las mujeres
[Música]
y la conmemoración de este 8 de marzo en
Francia estuvo marcada por la reforma la
ley de la jubilaciones primero porque
cayó un día después de una gran huelga
convocada en contra de este proyecto del
gobierno de Manuel macron y Porque
además si con el nuevo sistema todo el
mundo va a tener que trabajar más las
mujeres tendrán que hacerlo aún más
tiempo si quieren obtener una pensión
completa por eso la conmemoración tomó
la forma de una huelga feminista a lo
largo de todo el país Francia en foco
compresó con un grupo de mujeres a
quienes el trabajo doméstico les paso
factura a la hora de pensionarse
[Música]
abulcado la calle a miles de personas en
toda Francia la reforma de la
jubilaciones es el gran tema social de
este inicio de año y las mujeres han
estado muy presentes en las protestas
la jubilación es el balance de toda una
carrera y para ellas marca el fin de una
vida de desigualdad
en Francia la jubilaciones de las
mujeres son 40 por ciento más bajas que
las de los hombres Pero cómo se llegó a
esta situación
[Risas]
estas tres abuelas viven bajo el nivel
de pobreza es decir ganan menos de mil
ciento dos euros al mes como una
jubilada de cada día
es el resultado de una carrera
interrumpida
Yo me casé y mi marido no quería que yo
trabajara tuvimos un niño quería que yo
lo criara y eso a mí me interesaba yo no
tenía mucha preparación entonces
trabajaba en una empresa de zapatos y
cuando mi hijo se casó mi marido me dijo
ahora me voy quiero vivir y bailar tuve
que pedir la ayuda el sueldo de
solidaridad activa bueno
es una vergüenza
para ganar un poco más mastín a sus 72
años hace planchado a domicilio y eso
pese a vivir con una enfermedad
respiratoria cuando eso no es suficiente
su hijo le ayuda discretamente
a veces abre el refrigerador y ve que no
hay nada va a hacer las compras y me las
trae Y me da vergüenza soy yo quien
debería ayudarlo
[Música]
durante décadas Martín hizo la limpieza
en casas particulares hasta seis horas
diarias pero el trabajo no declarado no
es considerado En la jubilación
Cuando se es joven Cuando se tiene 25 o
30 años no se piensa en la jubilación
desgraciadamente y de repente la vida se
nos viene encima de un día para otro
éramos muchas en la misma situación
mujeres que trabajábamos en negro y los
maridos se imponían mientras nosotras
nos ocupábamos de los niños Esa era la
lógica
hoy la mayoría de las mujeres declaran
sus ingresos pero sus sueldos y
jubilaciones siguen siendo impactados
por el trabajo doméstico del total de
demandas de trabajo a tiempo parcial un
80% son hechas por mujeres
lo más común es no trabajar el miércoles
para ocuparse de los niños Pues no hay
escuela ese día
Alexandra está en ese caso es auxiliar
de puericultura su trabajo es ocuparse
de los bebés del personal del hospital y
cuando sale de la guardería no hay
tiempo que perder debe rápidamente
regresar a casa
cuando salgo del trabajo comienza mi
segundo día de trabajo debo hacer el
aseo la limpieza lavar la ropa todo lo
que las mujeres hacen cotidianamente
Alexandra se puso a trabajar media
jornada cuando nació su segunda hija
Eliana su marido siguió a tiempo
completo
esta situación temporal se prolongó en
el tiempo cuando Algunos años después un
retraso le fue diagnosticado a su hija
menor
imposible ocuparse de ella trabajando a
tiempo completo La mayoría de los
asistentes o trabajadores domésticos son
mujeres en Francia en obligación
[Música]
fue casi una obligación porque entre los
pedos psiquiatras los especialistas en
psicomotricidad los ortopedas los
ortofonistas todas esas citas hay que
fijarlas si no tuviera este tiempo
parcial sería muy complicado porque el
miércoles es el día que yo destino para
fijar todas esas visitas médicas es una
agenda muy apretada
pese a sus 20 años de servicio
está auxiliar de puericultura gana 1700
euros al mes
es común que los trabajos de cuidado y
ayuda a las personas sean
mayoritariamente ejercidos por mujeres y
no sean los mejor remunerados
Alexandra No espera tener una gran
jubilación
No sé lo que voy a recibir ni siquiera
ha hecho la simulación porque me voy a
deprimir más que nada
Y si bien esta madre no se arrepiente
del tiempo dedicado a sus hijas
les aconseja elegir un trabajo mejor
pagado que el suyo
en Francia existe la desigualdad
salarial una mujer gana menos que su
equivalente masculino Esto se debe en
parte al fenómeno de la buena alumna una
niña hace todo por agradar a sus padres
y a sus profesores y luego repite este
esquema en la edad adulta en el trabajo
sin embargo hay quienes están tratando
de cambiar esa actitud
Qué futuro profesional Espera a estas
niñas francesas
este el profesora de colegio en un
barrio sensible de la periferia de dijon
intenta ampliar las posibilidades de
futuro a sus alumnos de segundo básico
en la pensión rápido
vimos que algunos alumnos habían
precisado que los oficios eran para
todos iguales chica o chico tenemos
derecho a elegir Pero eso será así
también en su vida de adulto que
elección van a hacer que va a ocurrir
con ellos hay una diferencia entre la
teoría y la práctica porque decir no es
hacer y a veces van a tener que seguir
algunas obligaciones como en la familia
quien se va a ocupar de los niños la
familia
en teoría las niñas tienen una ventaja
en esta clase así como en la media
nacional son mejores alumnas que los
niños son perfeccionistas para
satisfacer a las autoridades de la
escuela y de la familia
las niñas siempre buscan agradar les
gusta trabajar bien por la profesora por
la mamá o el papá a diferencia de los
chicos que son más egoístas lo pongo
entre comillas Pero es verdad que
piensan menos en eso en agradarme
trabajan solo para ellos es algo que uno
ve cotidianamente y Es verdaderamente un
contraste entre las niñas y los niños
este síndrome de la buena alumna es un
freno Cuando se llega al mercado de
trabajo en las empresas las mujeres
siempre buscan ir en el sentido de sus
superiores jerárquicos
Aunque eso vayan detrimento de su
interés Financiero
madre soltera Carol lucha contra este
síndrome de la buena alumna desde que
entró a un banco a los 18 años
muchas veces ha negociado su sueldo pero
no tanto como podría por miedo a
decepcionar
[Música]
me da miedo pasar por la quisquillosa
que reclama que se queja y que tiene
necesidad de entrar en conflicto con su
empleador o gerente por poca cosa
después de 20 años de carrera Carol va a
comenzar un nuevo trabajo entonces
decidió contactar a una consejera
salarial
esta mujer prepara sus congéneres para
negociar sus salarios
emocional
Carol vino con una idea de su valor
mucho más bajo de lo que ella amerita y
del justo precio de sus capacidades y su
calificación y eso es muy sintomático de
las mujeres
Si te acuerdas con elementos factuales
tú me ayudaste a determinar un margen de
salario que yo encontraba muy elevado Sí
muy elevado diría yo
lo que demuestra que yo tenía un
problema con respecto a mi valor Incluso
si yo valgo esta remuneración voy a ser
capaz de decirlo verbalizarlo y después
hay que asumirlo y reconocerlo para que
verdaderamente decir sí es esto y una
vez que uno dice sí tengo que decirlo
tengo que soportar la reacción de la
persona que tengo enfrente
yo creo que las empresas tienen que
decidir pagar bien a las mujeres en vez
de destinar grandes presupuestos a su
comunicación interna y externa y hacer
un lavado de imagen feminista deberían
destinar ese presupuesto a resolver las
desigualdades salariales
al final Carol obtuvo un sueldo 20% más
elevado de aquel al que ella había
apuntado inicialmente superando La
Brecha salarial hombre mujer en Francia
en promedio la francesas ganan un 16%
menos que los franceses decenas centenas
y hasta miles de euros de diferencia en
la nómina de salario que multiplicados
por los años de servicio crean una
verdadera diferencia a la hora de
jubilarse y hasta aquí este capítulo de
Francia enfoco Muchas gracias por su
compañía y hasta una próxima por las
pantallas de Franz 24 o en France 24.com
[Música]